as coronavirus cases surge in the u.s.
Latino communities are suffering high
rates of infections the CDC says Latinos
are hospitalized from the virus at more
than four times the rate of white
Americans CBS News special the CBS News
special panda Mia Latinos in crisis
looks at why this community is
vulnerable and shares the stories of
people on the front lines in this
preview ed O'Keefe talks to New York
State Assembly Member Catalina Cruz
about stepping up to help her hard-hit
community we are the epicenter of the
epicenter for many across the country
the last three months you realize how
many children are on the line have
upended their lives that means their
parents probably have to go back to work
so they sent the kids to pick it up
cutting has this many kids on the line
before and Latino leaders how many a
Russian can help based in Queens New
York Karolina Cruz a Colombian immigrant
is the first dream to serve in the New
York State Assembly
he's our really kind people who will get
to the end of the line and we have no
more food and they have four meals and
they'll turn around and give two to the
person behind them he's an angel in this
neighborhood her constituents let her
know when they like her I wanna keep
erbium a and when they don't
not the people that would've you see
what I mean by the morning of March 17th
five days before New York was ordered to
stay home Assemblywoman Catalina Cruz's
district office became a food pantry so
this is where we have the food set up
and we start giving it out and we come
today her team gives out at least 2,000
meals a day - every day the line wraps
around the block what's going through
your head as you walk the line but that
could have been me and my mom that had I
not become one of the lucky ones I'd be
on the line with my mom what does it say
that in the nation's largest city
allegedly the financial center of the
country and of the world an assembly
woman has to do this for her
constituents when they came time to help
my people they left us alone they left
this baloney headlines of people
Assemblywoman Catalina Cruz who is an
angel in her neighborhood Maria Elena
Salinas will anchor this special airing
Sunday she's with us from Miami Maria
Elena good morning why are Latino
communities especially vulnerable to
this virus good morning Anthony good to
talk to you but there are several
reasons one of them of course is a
medical factor Latinos are more prone to
get diabetes and heart disease there's
also the cultural factor which is many
multi-generational families are Latino
they live in small spaces that sometimes
prevents them from being able to social
distance but the main factor is that
they are essential workers that are out
there keeping the economy going and
they're doing jobs that cannot be done
from home and that's probably one of the
things that exposes the Latino community
more to this virus so what can
government officials do to help well
we're not seeing much help from the
federal government or from state
governments with the possible exception
of California and that's why you see
people local politicians just like
Catalina Cruz as you saw in the store
stepping up and helping their community
and what we have seen is that National
Hispanic civic organizations activists
advocates philanthropists have really
stepped up and the Hispanic community to
help the user platforms to advocate but
they also you know reach into their
pockets to be able to create some kind
of funds for for the Latino community
Elena does does immigration status
ultimately affect whether someone can
get a test or whether they're actually
going to seek treatment but
unfortunately it does it does prevent
them not having the necessary documents
legal documents immigration documents
it's really difficult because access to
health care or to adequate health care
is more complicated one of the reasons I
think also is even though during a
global pandemic everyone should have
access to testing to treatment there is
a certain fear among the undocumented
community that seeking that help seeking
that access is going to affect them that
you know it could their fear of
rejection fear of persecution but more
importantly fear of being able to access
their documents like maybe losing the
opportunity to get a green card there
are a lot of families struggling to make
ends meet during this pandemic very
really not what did practical advice
will there be for them in this special
this not only does not only talk about
the the problems that they face but also
some of the solutions and like you
mentioned the finances is probably one
of the most important ones since so many
Latinos have lost their jobs or lost
income and can't afford to pay their
rent can't afford to pay to put food on
the table media DRL in this special
talks to the president and CEO of the US
Hispanic Chamber of Commerce who gives
you a practical advice among among the
advice he gives is you know prioritize
your expenses don't be afraid to ask and
remind them that
fortune 500 companies failed several
times before they had to pick up and and
become successful again so there is
practical advice and there's a lot of
star power also in in this special we
have a Longoria
a Wilmer Valderrama a lot of the Latino
leaders and their community advocates
who are really stepping up to give
advice and hopefully you will watch
remember that is special is the first
one that CBS does with a complete crew
of Latino reporters all the journalists
in front of the camera are Latino and
most of the ones that work behind
cameras are also Latino so if you know
power of CBS Maria Elena Salinas thank
you so much panda Mia Latinos in crisis
will air Sunday night at 9:00 8:00
central on CBS n and is available now at
CBS news.com slash Panda Mia